que faire des enfants abandonnés des
jeunes délinquants
une préoccupation au 19e siècle lié à la
révolution industrielle
une paupérisation de la population le
musée de la ville tend à la faire
connaître à elancourt un orphelinat la
fondation méquignon une abbaye est un
lieu emblématique sa chapelle qui dit à
bellini forcément un lieu de culte donc
cette chapelle qui était qu avait une
pierre d'autel évidemment à la base on
était célébré des messes à laquelle
assistaient les orphelins de l'abbaye et
puis l'abbaye en elle même était tenu
par départ des bonnes soeurs dirigé par
au départ par la soeur gabrielle qui est
cofondatrice avec l'abbé méquignon de ce
lieu donc cette chapelle a été vraiment
centrale pour l'abbaye
c'était c'était le centre du domaine et
autour d'elle a été les établissements
d'accueil des enfants
l'abbé méquignon turé d'elancourt créé
son orphelinat dès 1859
la fondation est reconnue d'utilité
publique en 1866 donc là on va aller
voir le sait est donc centre de
formation aux métiers du bâtiment
de ville pour donc ça c'est
l'affectation actuelle de l'école une
idée de formation déjà présente 130 ans
plus tôt l'école d'horticulture le nôtre
est fondée en 1882 sur le modèle des
oeuvres de georges plongeante un juge
qu'ils considéraient les enfants
délinquants comme des victimes
elle prendra le nom de freedom jardiner
vertal en 1896 et elle fonctionnera
jusqu'en 1963 comme école d'horticulture
donc cette école elle avait bien sûr des
salles de classe comme toutes les écoles
mais surtout un parc et défaire pour
apprendre aux enfants à jardiner et
parlent à leur apprendre les vertus de
la terre il ya tout aussi une idée de
que la terre est bénéfique par rapport à
l'univers urbain qui lui était vicieux
et vicieux huissier un jardin à la
française un hâle anglaise dessert il
n'en reste aujourd'hui que ce bassin